aloha it's your friend esther and i'm
doing stand-up in your city perhaps
let's see i'm coming in january to salt
lake city nashville raleigh north
carolina austin texas indianapolis
philadelphia and chicago all those dates
are on esther on ice.com and check out
my clothing line sleepoverbyester.com
happy 2022 sluggies come see me on the
road i'm going to be out there all year
come see me at the milwaukee improv i'll
be in naples florida and tampa florida
and a bunch more dates coming up please
look on andylenderman.com
shows there are so many dates i can't
wait to meet you
[Music]
okay another week where
uh both of you guys are in hot costumes
and i look like this
well here's the thing you they go all
right the cop these are the costumes go
get them esther goes i don't want to do
anything so then us costumes get
forgotten for her but i
i why am i the ugly one always you i
feel like you're trying to change you
should be talking to your parents
honestly about this i don't think that's
for us i think you mean therapists talk
to god
so uh what's the deal with today
every past jobs everybody
jobs uh
first i want to know what op what were
your options and what for the outfits
yeah for past jobs i worked at equinox
what
i worked that's too unbelievable
how to find a costume
for that
um we just got your face and put it on
like a really like ripped girl's body
yeah
i did carry out at mongiano's briefly
um but i think tell us how briefly
actually
and is it just you were taking your food
out to the car
i think on my job i think i might have
you beat on how short of a stint a work
stint i've ever had why one day at a
shoe store one [ __ ] day that's what's
it what's his name bundy what's the shoe
bundy
um i did not last i was like [ __ ] this
and i left i didn't even collect the the
paycheck for that day of work
i've been 48 i've had a similar i when i
worked at hard rock cafe on hollywood
boulevard i only did the training
and then was let go before it came time
to perform well it's hard to order from
someone that doesn't get taller than the
counter
they have to lean over uh
what part of training did you not get
past the test
and i remember
all of i'm sure i've talked about this
before but like all of the
kids and the people in my group of
training were like studying hardcore
like we were going to each other's
apartments and studying and i was kind
of like
i'm gonna get through this on charm like
i'm gonna like really because that's how
i got through everything in my life but
it worked
but the can i tell you the big issue why
it didn't work out at hard rock is
because
we had to memorize every single
ingredient on the menu item for every
menu item including the alcohol
you guys alcohol have never tried it
it's a foreign language to me there was
no [ __ ] way i was going to remember
seven ingredients i don't take i don't
accept it in 40 drinks
i was a bartender i didn't know any of
the [ __ ] drinks but hard rock was
like corporate like it was no but i'm
just saying it's like
i was an alcoholic and i didn't remember
i didn't know the names of the what's
the main alcohol what's the main alcohol
under margarita esther
oh this is good it's
is it tequila
yes it is
and it has lime and
spicy spice correct sometimes
yeah
okay what about those around the room
chili spice
could
yeah
what is it um it's salt
salt pornographic what would you guys if
we were at a cocktail bar right now what
would you guys order uh a water no [ __ ]
if you were if if i wasn't a recovering
alcoholic wow esther it's a relapse
episode no she's like i do drugs now
everyone laughs
what would like a cool person like you
guys if you were just wanting to be like
if this we were
saying this is what you this is how i
knew people were underage i want a long
island iced tea or i want a rum and coke
why or lemon lemon drop or lemon drop
it's just like young like it's just the
drinks you know let's say we were this
is if we were on sex in the city and we
were all at our cocktail what would each
of our drinks be i would
only one thing i drink now it's just
mezcal and that's it and it would be
with a slice of orange and some salt and
that's it so the handsome young lad came
up to you was like i buy you a drink
yeah it would be should go i'll take
what you're having because that's a
lad's drink
i have ordered boyish too i always had
like i liked glenn livitz or something i
liked it yeah
some sort of scotch or
a bourbon on the rocks what would i
order what
oh so that's rude because everyone's
laughing maybe you wouldn't i don't know
and i don't understand why
well that's why you'd get that i just
don't understand why
except what you are [ __ ]
i was a whiskey girl too i was jaeger
though too that yeah i had to quit i
quit jaeger before i quit anything else
the last time i drank i had jaeger and
uh-oh
stop it all now yeah pints of jager i
told you i hooked up with a guy at a bar
like i was bartending in one bar and
then like two blocks down in santa fe
there was this other bar willie's and i
was hooking up with the bartender there
and i would go like
blow him in the bathroom and give me
points i mean it wasn't like an exchange
like that it wasn't a prostitute for
them but it just happened that way you
know what
speaking of like that sounds really
thrilling to me yeah like that is
something that i would do for sport not
for pleasure in any way
and i want to ask you guys before we get
into anything um are you into weird
fetishes that
involve like that are so seemingly
normal
that's not a true fetish
like for instance i know i was like i
think somebody has something they want
to tell you like do you ever think about
it
like would you ever do you have like for
instance like do you have like a postman
fetish like i want to be in you know
driving a mail truck
what's yours tell us yours a postman
bet you got something you want to say
say it i want to deliver mail
is that true
um i have weird ones i think you want to
do a little fetishist like a role is
that a fetish no
you want a job you want to do i'm not
sure
a circle back circle i think it's like
both like like for me
i feel like a role play that i gravitate
towards is like
i don't want to say
that dave's a girl
it's so at this point
it writes itself
really
it really writes itself i um no i don't
i want to hear say it i need you to say
it i feel like it's hot to be like like
an escort or something like i like that
oh totally really okay a thousand
percent to be paid yeah like what's your
thoughts but by your partner but like
todd yeah not like a stranger not a
stranger it's like a role play todd pays
me for sex that's funny
no it's not a joke we're not asking you
if it's funny you or not
yeah life is a joke
that is how i get through it
what is my role playing he's like i pay
todd for sex
life
thank you dear todd wait i do have that
fetish i'm not fetish i
i would you're like a kept man
i think we talked about this with hannah
i wouldn't be opposed to just like
having a [ __ ] boy
yeah but then you get them and it's like
i don't know i just feel like i've lived
on my fantasies honestly like anything i
dated the older guy i did all that i'm
like this isn't i had like a a rich
older guy when i was 21 that lived in
santa fe when i was a go-go dancer which
we'll get to
um who would he was like working on a
movie he came into town and
he's working a movie and he like would
take me to the spa and stuff and
it was just like take me to fancy
dinners but you guys would hook up yeah
that's fun we [ __ ] in the woods except
but i told you when we found them then i
had like a twig in my [ __ ] later
there's always like
always a twig in your [ __ ] after these
things you're saying like the reality of
it is not i've already done it i don't
know i guess i just don't i mean who
knows maybe i'll have a second wind of
all of this at some point but i just
feel like i've done it like i [ __ ] in
public i used to always bang in
bathrooms i just think it was funny to
like hook up like
where people peed like
like yeah let's go make up by the like
wall
people i said esther
not dogs
in esther's mind the dog park is just
people walking people
[Laughter]
but i will say
that i was listening to like a gwyneth
paltrow podcast don't know don't judge
me i don't know why like i'm not even
into that but
she did say they were talking about like
young women's sexuality and she was like
when she grew up she was taught like sex
is bad like don't ever talk about it
it's bad bad bad and she was saying how
like today it should be like that it's a
good thing that women should experience
pleasure and like even ask them like
what are they should explore young women
should be like what are your kinks and i
was like wow to hear someone like
gwyneth paltrow like miss like prissy
goop say that i was like oh i think i
bet you should get some goop and some
weird places on my body it's pretty
goopy i bet you there's a lot she's
steaming that [ __ ] for a reason why
does it need to be so flat why doesn't
it be so i get wrinkles out it depends
who you're surrounded by i think i got
the wrong message about sex um because a
lot of the people a lot of the women
around the world
yeah
besides all the rapings
besides the serial rapings
i had um what i saw was like women using
it to sort of get by
and women that i loved and really like
respected and like looked up to and i
thought it was just a way to
get what i needed in life like get what
you want is that what you're dressed as
that that's this that's the job you're
just asking
this right here why are you trying to
[ __ ] us
this right here guys is um i don't know
if you guys know but i worked for
abercrombie and fitch for a couple of
years this is a good advertisement this
is unreal unlikely the most unlikely
person to work at abercrombie
got recruited to work at well i've seen
your abs yeah you've been shirtless
outside that yes you're not white but
[ __ ] you're hot so like
but i'm saying like my insides don't
match their company policies i thought
it was a racist anyways
which it should it shouldn't be yes
but i did work at the glendale galleria
and um you know the saddest part about
that job was telling regular-sized girls
that we didn't have their size what
it was like nope we stopped at this
particular size and they were
regular-sized girls it's so funny how
abercrombie was like everything when i
was in middle school it was like
abercrombie was yeah it there was
nothing else and then i kind of got over
it i turned into more of a [ __ ] it
wasn't [ __ ] enough for me well i think
they would also i guess with my size
going in there getting the extra larges
it still looks pretty [ __ ]
i can't believe they've survived as a
company it's wild yeah there's so many
lawsuits you know what i think hollister
survived oh you mean ever coming home
same company hollister rule i think i'm
pretty sure how hollister stays afloat
every mexican person that comes in to
america shops at hollister
i think it's foreign not just i think
every foreign person is like the most
american thing yeah
i guess so i guess i was just i oh it's
like i only see mexicans dressing in
hollister like a like a like an american
fetish but it's like we don't wear it as
much as the not anymore
well that's the thing i was going to ask
it's like is it relevance like does it
have any sort of relevancy right now i
ever cried are they they're not doing
the hot guys outside anymore right now
no thank god they're not and you know
how they would protect themselves is
because they really just would hire what
they considered good looking employees
but to protect themselves they would
hire the uggos but they put them in the
stock room yes or work like the night
shift to like do the like the folding
were you in the stock room with johnny
rockets sometimes
it was small how long did you work there
again i worked there
no i worked there like
maybe like set six months or something
like three weeks no i was there a while
i got i went and got hired their senior
year of high school and then worked
halfway through the towards the end of
the summer and it was before you know
going to college and i got my boyfriend
a job there
and then he [ __ ] started he left me
for another waitress at johnny rocky and
did you quit right after that yeah is
that the one you wrote and then you were
in her dance class the one no that's
someone else oh you get cheated
that's cute
esther i want to know how you um would
take my order okay well we'll start with
annie well first of all welcome to
johnny rockets um
right away i remember where's the sound
coming from i don't see it where are you
sir
is there a mouse i think i hear a mouse
i actually
thrived at johnny rockets because we had
the 50s music we made the smiley face
ketchup i i got by on my charm
i remember old ladies would come up to
me and be like your service is just like
in the old days too because you're so
friendly and happy
and slow they had such lower
expectations back in the day they didn't
have like
the internet they weren't used to
getting things right away but huge pro
tip
everyone always wonders do the burgers
come with fries they don't you have to
order your fries separate blasphemy so
people were always a little bit annoyed
because the burgers were a more premium
did you tell them ahead of time i would
always be like just so you guys know
like you have to order the fries
separate with your little hands
we made our own milkshake so i scooped
the ice cream myself
um oreo milkshake i i left every ship i
would be like i need to make sure that
person does not touch my food
i need a different food runner
what if you were just the food runner
that would have been cute we serve some
a midwest classic that you won't see
normally is um a slice of apple pie with
a slice of cheese on top did you have to
do that yes you're on ketchup duty
smiley face
no did carlos have to wear an outfit too
when he came to do the smiley face for
you guys wasn't born yet
esther miss i've been here for 20
minutes now you've been giving me the
specials but still no menu oh okay let
me um what are yeah what are the
specials of the day so we don't have
specials here at johnny rockets it's a
standard menu but i think you guys will
be really happy with your choices sorry
one second such a liar little actress
look at her
now
oh to go that's a little rude trying to
get rid of us already that's pete the
producer's phone
annie i want you to ask i want you to
ask her
i want you to order the way you think
esther would order can you read the menu
to me sure
so would you are you in the mood for a
burger but what's the where's the meat
from
oh yeah i see this is i see what this is
you didn't see for a while
oh i remember the route 66 i always
thought sounded so weird but was so
popular it's swiss cheese grilled
mushrooms caramelized onions and mayo
and we have that as a single or a double
option
guys if this is interesting to the
audience i don't know what interesting
is anyone here's my question
does anyone have johnny rockets fetish
is anyone getting turned on does anybody
here's what i want to know
can we bring up rhubarb pie
oh i want to know that do you have any
desserts yes we i just as i said we have
a slice of apple pie we have milkshakes
they're hand scooped and we offer cheese
hand scooped you just
huh
i know you think it's funny but hand
scooped is a big deal in the milkshake
game a lot of them don't actually hand
scoop the ice cream
i'm gonna go home i do like no no i like
i like a little like
a hint of just
like a chocolate suffering like i want
yeah i want my my server to be like
slammed and like oh now i gotta scoop
the [ __ ] ice cream and we we that's
what i'm paying for the servers make the
milkshakes and we make the fries
ourselves too so how do you make the
fries you just dip them
wow
they go in a basket and you dip them in
the oil in the timer they let you have
those responsibilities and then you can
add chili and cheese what was your
hourly pay you know what's crazy is in
illinois
waiter when i was working we got servers
got like three dollars an hour yeah and
you worked off tips but in california
servers get like i think i got like
when i was a waitress in new york not
that long ago like maybe 10 years ago it
was 2 50 i think what yeah you got 2 50
cents and then you get your tips
yeah so that's why
you get and then you get taxed on
automatically taxed on 10 of your tips
so if people pay you under tip you under
10 you're paying
i mean imagine the rage bubbling inside
you when just no one tips and there are
what's [ __ ] up is that like tipping is
sort of a not just an american thing but
it's like sort of an american thing in
other countries they don't tip a lot so
you have a lot of foreigners that come
through who don't don't understand the
tipping culture so they might tip you
really poorly you know and um i can't
imagine
having to hand scoop something and then
get paid two bucks yeah well that is
also a big reason why i started to
realize that hard rock cafe on hollywood
boulevard wasn't going to be good
because it was going to be all tourists
and they would have been
foreign yeah yeah i had these french
people come in once
to when i worked at life cafe it's where
jonathan larson wrote rent
holy [ __ ] yes it was thompson square
park it was on 10th and b no day by two
but i made a big point to not know any
of the songs okay well that's people
what's your favorite song about the last
one
the holidays are stressful we did it
and
we got through it but we are still
needing a little help aren't we we got
the new year coming up we got to figure
out what our intentions are life is
stressful it's stressful work is
stressful that's why we all love our
sponsor better help oh thank you better
help check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
connect in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
and it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online and you can send a
message to your counselor at any time
and you know
i'm up late and honestly it's about to
be a new year and like
if you're not getting your mental health
game on point like i don't know what
you're doing
because it's the
single most important thing to having a
happy successful life and if i were a
single girl that would be just a
requirement for me like ask the guy like
how what's your mental health game like
are you getting help are you seeing it
there if a guy is better get
literally if a guy is not getting help
like that like a therapist or better
help
mm-hmm it's a wrap don't waste your time
there's no reason and this service is
available available to clients worldwide
find the particular expertise you need
online don't limit yourself to
counselors located near you we want you
to start living a happier life today and
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's
betterhelp.hep.com
trash tuesday i love stitch fix
i love it i all i've wanted my whole
life is to just have
someone pick my clothes out for me and
bring them to me yeah and then you get
to choose too you don't need to keep all
the stuff that they mail you and then
you they let you send it back it's i
honestly when i go i've had so many
times i've gone to the store and i get
all the stuff i do the shopping i see
the line and i go nope and i just leave
it same i just leave it and go sorry to
all the retail workers that have had to
deal with that but i gotta go
i have a panic attack stitch fix fixes
all of that
introducing by the way stitch fix
freestyle a shop that is built just for
you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle whether
you're looking for a brand you love or
to try a new one which is so much fun at
stitchfix freestyle you can shop a range
of over a thousand brands personalized
to your size and fit it is so convenient
where's it's been my whole life like why
didn't i have this when i was a teenager
with styles for workouts to work where
for lounging around the house or for a
night out on the town stitch fix
freestyle has closed for any occasion
plus there's no subscription required
which is this jewish girl's favorite
part
and they offer free shipping returns and
exchanges get started today by filling
out your style quiz at stitchfix.com
tuesday that's stitchfix.com tuesday to
try stitch fix freestyle
stitchfix.com
tuesday so much fun
[Music]
but we had these like rent registers so
people would come from all over there
were a lot of japanese fans there was a
lot of japanese people that would come
and like order they'd find the cheapest
thing on the menu and they give you
exact change and then they come just to
sign the rent register which was just
like a book and people would like sign
that they were there but these this
group of french people once came in and
they ordered just drinks which you know
you're a little bit like okay we're not
gonna be getting any sales today but
they ordered just drinks they wanted
these refills they're being so annoying
but i was still being nice
and uh i bring them their drinks i bring
them their check um they
in the place where it's supposed to be
tip they have a frowny face and they
wrote um you were rude to us because
we're french and you didn't think we
were gonna tip
and i wasn't rude to that i like wasn't
rude to them i was like
this is such a fun french scam to like
you've you've gaslit me that's my fault
i didn't you know and and then my other
customers like all my regulars because i
was like look i wasn't a good waitress
you weren't gonna get the right food but
you're gonna fun in the process okay
tip the personality i always said and
the tits
are not the tits i go don't tip the tits
tip the personality and then my god so
that i used to get i sometimes i would
go to people and i would go i would go
50 tip is
it would it would be rude to get
anything less than a 50 tip just like
joking but then sometimes they would
give me a 50 tip it was crazy you as a
server is the equivalent of like being
at a show where it's an ambush open mic
yeah it's an open it wasn't and i did
have an open mic at life cafe called
living it up or not an open mic
show what are your thoughts on this my
friend who was a server at tony romo you
know how you have to automatically add
gratuity if it's over like six people
yes you do not tell them and you hope
they double ground is that what you're
gonna say right but there was this fan
i'll tell you guys who it is later but
he came in with a party of like 13
people and she was slammed at [ __ ]
tony roma's like 15 years ago and she
served him
and she added the gratuity and you know
what he said
he was like
if you had not added this i would have
given you quadruple the tip like he
thought it was rude that she did that
like who do you think it's just this
it's just the system everywhere
but saying like how [ __ ] dare you
think i wouldn't tip you so you
automatically regret it and she was like
no it's i had to like this is policy if
you want to think people are being
racist towards you you will find
evidence and a lot of times it's just uh
the the anagram yeah but that was so
weird with the french people i was like
i'm not like being racist or like
discriminating against you
yeah i just i'm not that good at my job
[Laughter]
no but i think the autograph thing was
like the dream was when they wouldn't
notice that you autographed and they
would double you're like oh thank you
jesus oh yeah oh i just got so much
money
i'm ready i think in australia they
don't work for tips but their servers
get like a minimum of like 25 yeah i
remember when i was in australia they're
yeah you're not there's no tipping but
they get they get
really good hourly that's better i think
it's better too it's so much no it's so
fun to have the excitement of not
knowing how much you're gonna make i'm
telling you i made the most out of that
i'm not trying to be the cocky
server but i made the most money i
always like it was so fun i got to talk
to people i was like working out bits
and that was i liked i literally loved
my job at giant rockets wait i did see
on tick tock that there was a stripper
who was like it's not the hottest girls
who leave with the most money
it's the the good talkers the real
people who can really charm you with a
personality who can yeah so dude i was
also i just want to say i was also the
host i was also the hottest waitress
that was the hottest way
trash tuesday challenge we all have to
work a night at a strip club and see who
makes the most money i'm going to lose
it so bad
yeah no but you'll be like the
mysterious one and he's gonna be like
the blonde chatty one you're gonna be
the one in sweatpants
i might be sucking the girl's nipples
you're gonna be the one giving kala
dollars
i have to forfeit why is she paying me
anything
i'll probably have to go for like a
school girl like i have to have my last
hurrah being like this honestly you
wearing the [ __ ] thing still looks
like a schoolgirl wearing the [ __ ]
thing or schoolboy i really think you
just got a bank on a pedophilia is what
i think like really really into that
yeah like let's goddamn down
we're going to the body shop tonight
you're going to be rich [ __ ] what looks
would you guys wait so you're a what are
you today well i am this is my
i'm i'm
the time in my life when i was a go good
when i was a
i was a nanny by day
and a
go-go dancer by night oh we got an
outfit change
don't try to look at my labia so you'd
watch the kids and then you take off
your overalls let's just say there was a
lot of glitter involved in all my jobs
and i would my knees hurt because i was
like would be dancing all night and then
i would go to like crouch down to like
play with the kids and i would collapse
to the ground i tried to get chicken
cutlets but i couldn't find any your
boobs look you're massive but i bought
the bombshell bra that i used to wear
and i have the glitter and i would
always i would always have like a fake
eyelash stuck to my cheek which would
have done i don't want to ruin my fake
spray tan so you already have experience
for the trash tuesday stripper challenge
i do have a little experience yeah god
but i was hoping it was going to be like
a waitressing challenge
oh well let's do like when we just get a
job one night great yep i feel like i'm
low on the stripper energy high on the
escort energy okay oh like i think i
would you'll [ __ ] you're an oddities
you know i'll [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] anything
all the way
the strippers are just like it's easier
i feel strippers are selling uh
fantasies yeah so are escorts escorts
are [ __ ] them though that's a fantasy
though yeah but see you guys are better
actors than me so the selling you guys
would nail
you don't mind maybe we still really
think esther's a good actor
interesting maybe we could this could we
could turn this into like a trash
tuesday business we're collect as an
escort we get 25 percent
good this is a good idea yeah
i i'm gonna take it one step further and
give myself compliment myself i say i
think that i have really good um
i'm high on the pimp energy i think i
could have a harem okay and and and take
good really good care of my girls like
really good cats like i'm mother hen
what would you do for us medical
insurance baby
medical insurance daycare
we test for all of it that testing is
just baseline yeah
listen you get your hair done whenever
you want mommy you know my my um
my roots are coming in that's okay babe
yeah get them done here you go would you
cover would you cover the cost for them
to get
um their cesarean scars lasered off oh
yeah you got keloids i gotcha babe
yeah i think i have like big mother hen
yeah yeah
esther
um
you left because of a boyfriend
i left johnny rockets yes because of a
boyfriend what is would you say you've
ever had a really bad boss
i don't think so i i don't i'd have to
really think but definitely not at
johnny rockets i absolutely loved my
managers
um
[Music]
yeah i feel like i've always
had a good relationship with my
superiors
right george are you that imagine
can't imagine um what about you guys
like did you have a boss as a go-go
dancer are you yeah it was this it was a
these two gay guys that owned the club
the nightclub
yeah they loved you
no i don't know why
it was very weird i had no one knew why
i was there it was like i was just there
drunk one night and my friend was the
manager and was like do you want to make
50 bucks an hour go dance on holy [ __ ]
like okay and then i would get 50 bucks
that's pretty good and then the owner
would come by and tip us i can't
remember what his name was but he would
tip us all 50 bucks and sometimes he
would pass you and not give you the [ __ ]
um i guess not tonight not for me um but
i would go in i remember because i would
get so drunk and i'd be like crying i
would drink because i needed like liquid
courage to do it
and um
and i felt like it would fall off the
podium i was like i was a bad gogo
dancer and so i went and cried was like
they're objectifying me they're trying
to touch me to the guy working goes you
don't have to work here like
nobody's making i was like oh
oh yeah is a go-go dancer you're just
like basically
dancing sexy but you keep your clothes
on yeah you wear like this outfit yeah
yeah that's like but i feel like that's
like a like a hard job you're sweating
you're [ __ ] yeah but it was only like
three hours three two nights a week
really it was like nothing it's you're
basically getting paid to do your
workout yeah
it was good but it was gross like and
one time the people i was nanning for
came to like see me dance and i was like
have you been trying to [ __ ] me okay
wait a second
crosstalk well i couldn't lie about
being a girl it's like i'm so obviously
coming from something
go
i think i invited them
okay so you're the problem
it's so weird i'm a go-go dancer and
you're a go-go queen
yeah my bad boss was a man named
but i used to work at la fitness and i
was in high school i was 16 and he would
have me come into his office and read
him my poems that you hate esther what
yeah then he would randomly at the end
of the week he'd cut me a check he'd be
like here's 200 bucks like have fun with
yourself so you were an escort
i guess i started young you were you
were an un you were an unassuming escort
yeah
and um
but that's i he was still relatively
nice and i appreciated the end of week
checks but now when i look back at it i
was like oh he was he was angling for
more it just never really happened but
ellie how old was he
in his late 40s or 50s i think so gross
i i had a bad boss but it wasn't a
molesty boss
i had a boss at color me mine did i talk
about this i worked at colorado that was
my first job i was 15 i think
yeah i worked at color me mine
in philadelphia and the owner was this
really insane bipolar woman like i mean
really really crazy
and
uh right before christmas would there be
like a limit like if you want to finish
like if you want to put your kids hand
print on a thing and give it to their
grandparents you need to get it in by
this time and we guarantee it'll be
fired and ready to go for christmas
so that time comes around and it's like
our busiest time
and
the owner is going through a divorce
with her husband and is having a mental
break because she went to go
to court for her divorce hearing and
they pushed it just because it was the
holidays and things were busy or
something so like we have to push the
court date and she got fixated on the
mayor of philadelphia mayor ed rendell
and decided it was he was sabotaging her
and trying to ruin her life so she made
us shut down put all the paper that they
put on the tables on the windows we
papered up the windows and we had to put
a note that said none of your pieces are
going to be ready for christmas if you
have a problem with that call mayor ed
rendell oh wow and she had us put his
number there
and then she had she had gotten in a
fight with her her and her ex-husband
were meeting at a park to discuss
something and she brought like us a
spear that she had from like some
travels or something she had hanging on
her wall she brought the spear to like
attack him with and so he ran got in his
car
drove off she chased him got in a car
accident like hit a tree or something
she went forward and like she either
like spit coffee out or she threw up a
little she had like a little vomit here
and so she in that moment she doesn't
call the cops and call anyone she calls
our manager this guy neil who was like
probably 20 or something but i thought
he was an adult and he was a
photographer so he she made him bring
his camera take pictures of her looking
like she's dead in the car and then she
pasted together
a
philadelphia inquirer article like the
front page of the newspaper with that
picture and it says so and so died in
car crash
and then you turn that she fax that page
over to the mayor's office and then she
faxed another one said you wish mayor ed
rendell
i'm 15. i'm like um
my mom dropped me off like do i get a
ride home and then um this set the tone
for the rest of you so everyone's like
calling we had to put the phone off the
hook because everyone's calling the
mayor's the mayor's office is like what
the [ __ ] is going on why are we getting
these calls and then later she did uh
kill herself so oh yeah [ __ ]
not like while i was still working a
year a couple years later or whatever i
have a suicide boss
[Laughter]
i
the okay
hear me out
when i first moved to la right before i
moved here i went to my cousin's wedding
and there was a woman at her wedding
who was my dream woman she was a beverly
hills boss ass [ __ ] she was wearing a
bb
wrap dress
she was [ __ ] gorgeous perfect fake
nose just absolutely perfect and she
immediately took to me and we like spent
the whole wedding just chatting and i
was like asking her questions and she
was giving me all this life advice and
she's like oh if you're moving to la
like i live there
she's like you should come work for me
because i always need help i was like
great i'm i'll be there i'll let you
know when i come
so like you know fast forward six months
i end up dropping out of school i moved
to la
i call her she's like great come work
for me so literally like when i drove to
los angeles the next morning like i got
in somewhere what was the job
so was i i was just going to help her
assistant yeah
so literally got to la like sunday on a
sunday night at like you know 11 p.m i
started work for her the next morning on
monday i showed up at 7 a.m like
beautiful
like beverly hills mansion
and i walk in she's like i'm so glad
you're here she's in a robe she's like
my knee is hurting i need you to drive
today i was like what okay i literally
just got to ellie like where are the
phone books so basically like she just
like took me around and i was like her
helper
and also she had two kids so i would
kind of help with the kids and she was
like an l.a [ __ ] like in a good way but
also a bad way
because we went out to lunch and i
remember the kids wanted dessert and
when the waitress came to me she was
like esther doesn't need dessert she's
on a diet
and that's where it all began
i was like cool
what if i scoop it myself is that and
actually there was so much like early
day la trauma from this experience
because then when her one of her friends
came over to like help me get ready for
this woman's who was working for her
second wedding and she was sitting down
with me like packing gifts or whatever
and i remember the friend was like so
why'd you come to la and i was like
uh
to like
to do like creative stuff how old were
these people they were probably in their
40s like women in their 40s like from
l.a they're probably 28 but we're older
now so we're like that was probably no i
would say like late 30s early 40s and i
was 21 and
um so what brought you to la i'm like oh
i'm like really into comedy she's like
oh you didn't just come here to meet a
man and i was like no yeah but looking
back don't you wish
looking back i'm like that was great
advice
you pursue your dreams later yeah
but anyways so i had this like crazy
three-month like affair working for this
amazing woman and
she ended up firing me because like and
ultimately all i did was like eat all
her snacks and like i was bad at
everything
and
then during kovid for some reason dave
was talking about
actually a mutual friend of ours
who gets like these really like high-end
stock tips
and i know and i googled
this billionaire that like is a you know
three people removed from me but like
there's this billionaire
who i heard about and i googled him and
i noticed his last name was
the same last name as that woman and i
was like weird
oh my god i was like oh my god like i
always knew she was rich but i didn't
know her ex was a billionaire so i
google her and like what is shipped to
now and like i see that she was um
already on her third marriage like i was
involved in the second marriage and
she's already moved on a third
billionaire
oh another billionaire yeah she married
another billionaire and then some people
just know how to do that like everything
i've met one billionaire no clue they
were a billionaire this was like the
person to learn that from and then i
kept like googling her and she killed
herself
oh [ __ ] she hung herself yeah she
[ __ ] committed suicide damn okay do
not try to get a rich man it does not
end well but i was like why like i i was
just in so much shock when i discovered
it because i really had this woman on a
pedestal which i know sounds crazy but
sorry um no she had you on a pedestal so
she could look you in here
but i i was just like wow like
you can marry billionaires and still not
be happy
who would have thought you know what i
like this is what i take from this whole
thing this is where you learned how to
treat carlos
like do things for me
but most silly dreams rest in peace like
obviously is a very tragic story and i'm
very sad and i
appreciate all my time with her did she
leave jewels or heirlooms for you she
did not
her favorite little la girl
you should have stuck around longer
answer um
honestly how many free trial
subscriptions do you end up
getting that cost you like thousands of
dollars because you're stupid and you
don't cancel them
69.69 oh sorry actually 420
i didn't know that my niece had um
borrowed my ipad and subscribed to a
very expensive premium anime streaming
service
that i had just been paying for for the
last four years
who told you about it though who told
you about it true bill thank you true
bill
really we love we love a good anime but
not for that price so thank you true
bill trubill is the new app that helps
you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need or
want or you simply forgot about and on
average people save up to seven hundred
and twenty dollars a year with drew bill
do you know what true bill taught me
what
that i have two um
apple accounts and i had double
subscribed yeah
i double just subscribed to things that
i shouldn't have been subscribing to at
all
because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel and true makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and triple will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap
and your true bill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to you
guys don't fall for a subscription scam
start canceling today at trubille.com
trash tuesday go right now truebill.com
trash do say it could save you thousands
a year and we're not even kidding yeah
don't get scammed all right slug should
not be getting scammed
there's no shame
no
and
not always being able to get it up
but we'd like it to be up
because there's blue chew there's blue
there's no more excuses it's so easy
it's
chewable
you don't even have to say i don't like
swallowing pills just chew it
chew it and then you get to do it
we'll really appreciate it
[Laughter]
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost and you can take them anytime
day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises which is
kind of a gift because with this other
stuff that they're used to be like back
in the day you used to have to plan yes
and then way in advance and listen
things happen all right we didn't have
cell phones
how you couldn't even call someone
telling you we were gonna show up you
just left this guy with a raging heart
on
and he just what is he gonna do and what
i love is the process is so simple you
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within
days yep in a discrete package by the
way
um bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door
and the best part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at a pharmacy so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform blue chew can help and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew free when you
use our promo code tuesday at checkout
just be five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code tuesday to
receive your first month free visit
bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring the podcast
ladies bluechoo is exclusively for men
but the end result is something you'll
both enjoy so get your man to sign up
did you ever see the movie uh the map of
the stars
or a map of the stars it's a lot like
it's like a
like a rich hollywood woman and her
assistant stuff you might like it really
yeah it's really weird and creepy and it
has a lot of like there's a weird incest
the whole storyline is kind of an incest
storyline but i'm going to tell carlos
to watch it and then like
cliff notes
you're like i'm busy looking at the
ceiling
i can't be bothered with television
interrupting
i must do nothing this is such a good
point of how you are just the listener
and never talk when perfect i've never
heard that story i don't even know i'm
like you had a job more than johnny
rockets and i learned about johnny
rockets on the show and also like you
you're the best storyteller
what it's very from like linear it's
very clear from beginning to end
interesting stories don't have to have
that
i like to you don't know where it's
coming they're more fun when you don't
what are you guys thoughts on people who
don't share their food like if you're in
a group together and you're eating have
you ever been around someone who's been
like hey like don't touch my people yes
that's me and you know it no we shared
food
just last week i up until very recently
like had a phobia of a group dinner
where everyone shares like i i just
couldn't
i did not get that vibe from you at all
we shared a pierogi we split one
what's a pierogi remember bobby was like
this thing is the most delicious thing
on earth and we were like yeah yeah yeah
a pierogi is very it was like a little
green empanada
yeah it's like shaped like an empanada
what was that and there was cheese
inside were you that was you were the
potato you were the person
to be fair i don't think you were
technically there you were so in
disguise oh i was high yeah yeah yeah
um i am better about it now but i don't
know what about you are you
i like when people like i think it's
more fun to like have because you can
order everything but if someone doesn't
want to share i don't give a [ __ ] it's
fine that's good if that's like their
boundary i don't care but just tell me
ahead of time because i will be reaching
over i've definitely been the person at
a group dinner where i'm like okay like
you guys do your thing but i'm like i'll
have my rice i just want this and i
don't want anyone else to touch it which
i know is does that make me sound like a
jerk is that bad who cares just be
yourself
you're annoyed
you
[Music]
what is next question
i um i have this realized with my i
stopped smoking weed so it's four days i
haven't smoked weed how do you i feel
good i i am not it does not serve me
what it does for you it does not do for
me what does it do to you it uh
makes me eat too much it makes me like
just foggy headed i'm not focused on
things that i want to focus on i you
know i have this whole hypnosis thing i
want to do and i just like completely
start smoking weed again and just don't
even think about it okay it just keeps
me off track like it really like
aggravates my add it just like makes me
more
just you know and i think eventually it
builds up and it makes me like more
like raw in a way that's not good so how
does this feel now on day four it feels
great i feel good i mean i've done it
before i always enjoy quitting smoking
weed it always feels good and then i
convince myself it's like a fomo thing
like i'll be like well if esther can eat
weed then i should be able to eat weed
but it's like everyone like reacts
different to things you know
but i never like have that much fun it
doesn't make my experience more fun ever
but
i was the other day before i quit
smoking weed i've had two guests over
for the popcorn machine okay and that's
one of the drawers is the popcorn
machine
so we have and we have a big tv and a
surround sound i'm like come on let's
think about it
look how sad she is that she wasn't one
of those two people i was like wait
i can't be responsible for the
transportation though i might take you
up on that oh my god esther if we're
gonna become like if you want to become
like friend friend friends where i you
know what i realized it would have to be
what
i would have to hire a car service for
you to come to me your assistant
no we'll just get carlos
um
carl solves all the problems but so i
invited two couples over okay
two couples came over this was separate
you know two couples i have friends
i got friends
uh my the first couple was haley and
curtis my friends who i do ayahuasca
with curtis works with joe rogan at his
club
and um
okay so and then haley's a teacher cool
whatever anyway so they come over they
want to watch we have the big tv we got
surround sound it's so fun we're on a
camera but we're watching we're having a
good time todd makes popcorn i don't
know how to make it obviously like todd
make the popcorn he makes the popcorn
puts it in a bowl if you put it near me
it's not like people had maybe one
kernel each yes and i like i'm telling
you what
the second time it happened with the
second couple where i ate the entire
thing of popcorn and then i would make i
make todd make another one and then i
eat the next one too oh now i see why
you don't invite me over for fun i want
i want cup i don't want to be eating all
the popcorn i don't want to be popcorn
the great thing about i don't have
popcorn guilt at all that is such a
happy food for me i never feel bad so
load it up but todd make more but todd
knows if he makes more i'm gonna be mad
because i'm gonna eat it again
doesn't know what to do he's standing
while we're shaking at the machine
more or less no no todd has been trained
his mom's so crazy i love her vanessa
you're the best but she he has trained
for me he's got a cool slice he slices
that packet open he's like my
girlfriend's crazy and it's never going
to stop and that's just how it is
cool is a [ __ ] cucumber here's your
popcorn [ __ ]
and um but so the second time it
happened i realized i literally like
black out so the popcorn comes i black
out i wake up i'm like wasn't there a
tin man was there
i'm like where are my red shoes
so it has to stop and so popcorn is why
i stopped smoking weed
that's the real this is the worst thing
you could ever say to me like i'm upset
listen here's why i didn't hypnotize
myself to never smoke weed because for
the show
and for our
community and our entertainment our
community i
obviously eat edibles on the show and do
stuff like that if i hypnotize myself i
won't be able to do it so i'm not i'm
just not i'm just taking my break from
weed whoa
yeah because i'll never smoke a
cigarette again afterwards because of
hypnotism i it's in my identity now that
i'm not i don't smoke cigarettes i can't
like when i want i can't there's nothing
so being hypnotized works
what would you like to be hypnotized out
of j esther don't know
but i'm doing like a habits thing
i'm using it as like a habit to change a
bad habit i know exactly what i when i
wake up in the morning and if it's not a
morning where like oh you have to be
here you know like
shooting or whatever like a show
whatever
um
i will really lay in bed for like an
hour yeah i didn't thought the audience
might think you were going to a shooting
range and you had to clarify i did
clarify because of that what did you
shooting
no i meant shooting when i was said
shooting i was thinking of doll face and
when i said like a show i was thinking
of this which makes no sense because
they're the same thing i would like to
see you in the shooting range i would
love that we should definitely do that
we can bring my new gun
[Music]
oh what do you got
i don't know what it is todd bought it
but it's a good one it's the one from
pulp fiction
that's all i know
annie has a gun we all know the days of
this show are numbered because one of us
won't be around can you imagine me
bringing it
i want to go to tactical training for it
i want to learn how to like roll around
and shoot
i want to be able to pop up roll around
shoot shoot back
we used to go to the desert when i lived
in nevada and just shoot we'd um fill up
things with water like pumpkins and
stuff and we would just fire away all
day
uh
it has my vegas days but i have pictures
that i feel like do not cause you look
like a gun [ __ ] i look like a gun [ __ ]
that's great that's funny i look like a
george what the [ __ ] is going on with
george he's getting all horny about the
guns oh my god he hasn't been around us
without his child for a while so now
he's really going crazy george is a
banana break time
yes it is banana i'm sad i liked the
little banana oh he started getting
shorter ones to remind us of hawaii
do you guys have any new year's
resolutions bad i'd have to think about
that i'm not sure
kalila's like her resolution is not
seeing us and she doesn't know how to
explain it
on the street
and i know when you say don't freak out
you're talking to me
well oh am i supposed to wait yes wait
for the ball to drop
then i'll lose the foam
that's a good thing is not
the part
the bubbly you're supposed to pour it so
there's less foam yeah peeps
yes i love it when pete's here so i'm
not the only one getting i know well
when carlos is here you guys really get
a break you really got a break
um
i feel like this is gonna sound crazy
uh-oh every day is my new year's
resolution i've been like really working
on my [ __ ] so i don't have anything like
specific but every night is new year's
eve every night's new year's eve baby
i'm [ __ ]
celebrating that ball balls were
dropping what do you guys usually do for
new year's
stand up no you guys at the start when
you do stand up here like and then i saw
my dad's dick oh wait okay guys it's
time okay 10 yeah nine eight
that's been really crappy for me to be
on the road with bobby for new year's
just that in random interruption in the
beginning and then he's trying to look
for me in the crowd because we're
supposed to do a midnight kiss yeah oh
they're midnight kiss search yeah is a
nightmare
where's the misery you gotta go through
a crowd yeah and he's like babe babe
where the [ __ ] are you but he's on cut
to midnight as a new year's update i
have a handcuff kalila
five minutes before midnight
i um
yeah i was talking to this girl today
who said that she um
she and her friend
who she had like a falling out with so
they're not doing it this year but they
would always do like a lead a meditation
through
new year's oh that's cool because she's
like why would we be partying and
getting wasted the things that we're
doing that are kind of like our gluttony
that we want to leave behind why would
we be going into the new year with that
and she's like i'm hungry yeah and then
once they meditate they do their like
what they want to manifest for the year
and their imagine that's a good point
because
having a hangover on the first day of
the calendar year
that's not it it doesn't make sense you
should be waking up early and getting a
head start i i love that and also like
my favorite new year's eve activity is
like going to the grocery store stocking
my fridge like
for what y2k that's stocking your fridge
she's like getting all the canned goods
to put in the basement for kova 22.
the hell is wrong with you i don't i
don't know you say things like they're
so normal that's what's like you know
how everyone does they stock up
everyone's wasted partying wait esther
do you do this store too or do you just
chill it out i've only done the store a
few times i don't like being in west
hollywood on new year's eve do you oh
i'm sorry did you think it was the fun
of being at your home club no no you're
on the road with a bunch of weirdos like
why the [ __ ] did you come to the show oh
i've done this comedy store on new
year's eve
yeah have you ever done it on halloween
dressed up
no
i've seen some really epic costumes
we're like that is nudity we're like wow
girl in hollywood yeah um
what's going on say the name say the
name i'll just say the name cause it's
not even any shade i like her and she's
cool and she's pregnant and [ __ ] now but
elizabeth came in like uh she was ronda
rousey once but she's like
she's she's like
she's like not the same ripped as you
because she's thicker than you so she's
like she's like
where me like she's like got like the
side cuts the britney spears so and then
she'll like she had like really low cut
like boxer shorts i feel like and she
came in she was like when it was like
your body's so hot it's very weird it's
like very distracting on stage
but she can't remember when she came in
the hat
um
i don't know that's all
that's gonna be the other name and edit
it out who else was it i don't know no i
just i'm trying to think of anyone else
like i just remember her coming and i
was like wow you are
naked that is weird it's probably really
cold out too what else i feel like if
she didn't have such a good body it
wouldn't have been as like surprising
if you don't have a good body it's
it's a funny costume it's a fun better
costume it's just like imagine if you're
like i'm rhonda
off season when i'm not trying to cut
weights but i think that she literally
like maybe she trained for that because
i like that too i like to have like i
trained for hawaii and now i'm going to
train for our billboard shoot
whatever that is
by the way george can i just tell you
you sang i need to know whether you guys
want to do the billboard or the live
show first is why would they have to be
can't they be next to each other can't
they be done at the same time uh
they're slow some things move slow but
we could do back-to-back weeks i just
need to know what to prioritize right
now because we're so close on everything
right okay and have you talked to bart
because bart keeps hitting us up about
about live streaming i think we should
consult esther our business manager
ultimately for the answer oh i spent
some money yesterday whatever we can do
to keep the costs down i'm a happy
person and i'm here to keep the costs up
and her unhappy
i thrive when esther's miserable that is
why the show works
are we going to have a sip or
this is this martinelli's
shout out
to the younger years
no i think we should um
say something to the slug fam and wish
him well yeah
um but i'm not good at that so you guys
do the new year's speech all right
kalila's not good at podcasting i think
she's really good at so the thing she's
really excellent at she's not good at it
but
um all right slugs
um 20 20 was wild was it not 20 21.
i think i'm actually that dumb like
that's well
yes we think you don't know what year 30
20 was a rough year but i'll tell you
one good thing that came out of it
we came up with a idea for 2021. true
which was
this podcast
it shockingly has worked
so weird
um on camera everything is excellent and
that's all you need to know no it's good
it's the best it's like so easy it's so
fun it's such a treat like
on the road meeting all of you guys has
been incredible talking to you guys the
energy that you feel towards us we feel
back at you we're all so happy and so
excited that you are entertained by our
[ __ ] like we really are yeah and
what about the fact like now i feel like
i have a safe space where i can share
what i'm going through in my life and
what i'm feeling about certain things
the fact you think this is a safe space
is how crazy you are do you see when
people are like she's too mean to esther
i'm like it's her safety she likes it
it's where she wants to be
but like i feel like we found this
community of slugs that understand us
and we understand them
and especially meeting them on the road
has been like a huge deal i don't know
i'm just i do feel
grateful
for you guys honestly
it pains me to say it
but i feel so grateful that you guys are
people that exist in the same timeline
as me is that why you didn't eat your
banana
she's now she's back to no bananas i'm
banana buy banana while you guys have
your drink um
yeah what else kyla say something i'm
not on the road like you guys so i don't
see this community as much right you
haven't felt um but i do feel
a different kind of love like i i've
been doing tiger belly for seven years
now and sitting next to bobby is a
different dynamic and i do feel
a little bit more loved here
um with the fan base that we've created
oh i thought he meant by us so i was
like that's real no no not in this room
not in this room specifically but just
by you know like i read all of your
messages
um there isn't one that i miss and
honestly it's just nice to have a girl
gang and the boy slugs and we love our
words yeah generally [ __ ] open how
cool and accepting of
three very different people on on mics
you know we're not your
you know we're crass we're not your
prototypical
girls next door
but thank you for accepting us just the
way we are in all of our
faulty faulty ways we're like if three
weird women moved into the house next to
you and you're like what's up with them
yeah we're like the what were the girls
the okay the three witches in um hocus
pocus yeah which one am i bette midler
yeah do i get people no you're sarah
jessica parker because you're blonde
which is so unfair okay what are you
are we gonna go i'm kathy najimy and
she's
kathy najimy's character is very cute
though but you're right annie's
i'm bette midler i'm happy to be ben
midler yeah that's that is kind of the
best yeah
i tried to be her but nobody
and i am still posh i do want to say
your number for this new year i want to
let everyone know i'm [ __ ] posh no
one can say anything about it it's done
agreed this is me they don't say i have
my gun
you're gonna have to prove it
tie your hair oh this pocket is getting
real different now that they know about
my i'm packing
all right well
cheers thank you this has been such a
good year i've had such a good time i'm
excited for more
far enough
yeah it was very symbiotic
which of you is going to move like i
mean it could have been a more
there couldn't have been a greater
parallel to our relationship than that
exact moment the only thing that would
have been better though is mutual
goodbye
carlos would you come in here and uh
that's what i was gonna say yeah if
carlos came and like clinked to them it
would have been perfect
or todd todd just help todd god damn it
it's actually quite delicious i know i
love it i love this apple cider can we
talk about the sharing food thing
because i want to know what your
feelings why it annoys you
oh no mine is just um i don't know how
to make of someone like that i have no
judgments about people and they're
sharing foods i just don't understand it
because
like it's always family style eating in
like asian culture
um it's like
you know what's mine is yours like my
first day in uh in the philippines yeah
and that that's fun unless you're
standing next to bobby
yeah
half the food that goes in his mouth
comes back out
[Laughter]
this looks really good but i want to
stand over there next to somebody else
oh that is funny
esther thank you for not sharing food no
well you are helping us it is like a
germ thing for me because people
sometimes there's no serving spoon and
people just go in with their but are you
saving us from your germs
yeah
[Laughter]
i think like i feel like are you saying
that like if this is something that they
don't do then you're like i don't know
where you are in the rest of the world
too i just don't like here's my thing
for sure if a guy was like that i would
not date him i agree that's like because
i'm like what the [ __ ] dude like you
should be able to
you have communal eating right i had a
boyfriend with ptsd who
like hated his mother so much for her
beating him um but he still liked her
but he was you know it was in there he
um if you went to reach for his food it
was like a dog like he would be so mad
and he's like oh and then he would go
into a whole thing about his mom how his
mom would never share food oh [ __ ] and
he would get back into it and you're
like oh okay um i will get my own thank
you but that then he became like his mom
yeah he would turn into yeah and he
would go back into the thing
guys if your ptsd you can get through it
you gotta work on it please lord god i
had i once dated a guy who in the middle
of the night had really bad dreams i
swear to god like his past life was a
nom or something yeah because he would
hold him down yeah that's how he was too
what is that scary he would hold you
down he would hold me down or like grab
me yeah and i'd like pull away and he
would like yeah it's but he would have
terrorists in my face he'd go like he'd
go i'm dying i'm dying and i'm like
you're alive please go over there yeah
yeah i'm dying i'm done like it would be
more like help me i'm dying and i'm like
no wow i really haven't dated much
you guys both have gotten like squeezed
in the night
i didn't get squeezed okay
i got yellow uh
yelled into giving [ __ ] though
when i was in a dead slumber but
fantastic
oh i was like that was a racket annie i
think
it's a bit weird when your ptsd's end up
with their d and your p p md
what do you guys want for 2022
i want more slugs i want more travel i
want to be doing more
stand up i want to expand my set i want
to keep entertaining people i want to
keep honing in on the things that i feel
like i'm here to do and it's just been
so fun i just want to keep writing what
about you esther i feel very similar i
want this show to continue to thrive
um
i feel super proud like of how
far and fast we've gotten and i just
want to keep going
um and maybe
we'll get all got real tattoos that
match i don't know they all say kalylah
has got a kaleidoscope
that's actually so funny to get your own
name yeah wait that one there are people
that do that that's amazing i always
wonder that it's like marrying yourself
like are you are you do you think you're
gonna forget who you are that you need a
reminder yeah oh my god memento oh
that's what i wanted to ask speaking of
names when you meet someone who has the
name who has
named annie or esther are you freaked
out by that at all
because it's so rare for me yeah does it
ever happen to you so you have to go to
the old folks home
esther's hanging out at the holocaust
memorial hearing her name left and right
it's so true i want to know what the
feeling is like because i've never met
anyone named kalaila because i'm like i
would be so freaked out that's not you
if someone's like i'm kaleila i'm like
no you're not no the [ __ ] you're not i'd
probably fight them well that is well it
was like a weird name your kids kalila
they're gonna get their ass yeah a lot
of babies are named kalila now they'll
always send me the baby pictures in it i
like that because they're babies but if
an adult
my age where they're like i'm kalylah i
would [ __ ] just drop that thing so
funny that even
though people love you esther they'll
never name their kid afterwards never
it's a whole it's like could be totally
okay
i actually do think though that my name
will come back it's already coming back
because it's it's been so old but when i
had it it was not in style i think um
i've had a lot of annie's in my life
there was annie cox and annie dick there
was a girl my college name any dick i
was friends with and the girl on my
quaker youth retreats wasn't how do you
feel like do you what do you call them
by their last name or do you call them
annie
i call them annie but i was never that
close i mean annie dick i was close with
but i it's hard to get close to someone
with your name realize what i'm saying
like you feel weird who's are you
talking to me or her it's like so
confusing well i heard that when people
have the same names they just call each
other by the last names oh yeah and i
feel like at my i went to a small school
high school college and uh both of them
were small but my college so they i was
flashing annie because i used to always
flash my tits
that was how they knew me that's a great
name i just called you flash the flat oh
my god guys i have a new name i love the
flash that's such a good name i feel
like you're flash
too junior flashy
i used to flash people but that name i
know a person that had the nickname
actually jenna's ex-boyfriend his
nickname was the flash hi
i don't know came fast was he fat
yeah that's interesting
i don't know
no i have no idea when he came or not i
like fast comers
you're not you like fast i love fast
comers yeah it's not a problem yeah it's
not a problem for me long comers when
they think they're doing you a favor
you're like oh my gosh stop with the
long coming guys this is a crazy thing
that i just thought about
i was thinking about all the guys i
dated when i was in my early 20s which
was like two whatever but how they came
really fast and like
because they were hotter i'm like is it
because is it because they were young or
is it because i was 21 and they're
[ __ ] 21 year olds
they're young yeah i think it takes time
because i've like if i ask bobby or my
friends now who are in their 30s they
all came fast when they were younger but
then you kind of like learn how to
manage the
that part of yeah okay so i was like is
this a me issue
yeah
it takes
[Laughter]
we're calling out we're [ __ ] again
that is i did hook up with one of my
ex-boyfriends and this was so painful
he like afterwards he was like pulling
up pictures of us in college and he was
like oh look how hot you were when you
were 21. [ __ ] i was like i just [ __ ]
you no
and i think i'm hotter than that because
i'm not a pedophile so i'm like yeah
look at that i'm like i was like my
cheeks were so puffy like i was so
little
yeah i was so young like okay someone
once said to me and he really thought he
was paying me a compliment
he was like you know what i love about
your face
how big your pores are on your cheeks
that's crazy he didn't mean pores he
must have meant like the absolutely no
because i do have like very visible
pores right here why would someone be
but
he was like no i love that he's like i
love that
and i'm like please never tell your next
girlfriend that you love her gigantic
[ __ ] pores
guys i'm going to take you to get ivs
high glutathione
juice i mean i got it too yesterday i
mean i have a spray tan too so yeah i
was going to say is that were you
did he like your pores like did he he
did he genuinely did did he come on your
face and like maybe thought he could get
you pregnant through that
what i like about you is i can get
pregnant without inserting
oh i do love a good
nut butt
oh what
you know when they can't come come in
you so they come in the back of you
in your butt yeah and your body just
blow their load all up in inside your
butt
like
to just let someone go in the butt just
for that it's like it hurts it's the
final thing it's just i don't like i'm
not into anal it hurts i don't either i
don't like it yeah they don't have to go
in to squirt it but yes they squirt on
the crack but the problem is i'm always
afraid it's going to drip in i'm going
to get pregnant that way
no you can prevent that
now i know what you're saying we're good
she has dated after all
she's like oh i did it a lot
like any of you dated that's really
weird
no i hate when i'm always like when you
have to when you have to go like clean
yourself you have to like hold you have
to cup it so it doesn't yeah everywhere
what are you guys thoughts on dudes that
don't offer a warm towel after to clean
i like the idea of them being like like
at the spa and they have like a warm
thing of asia i want it to be i want
them to have like a um a towel
to bring it to me yeah oh my god that's
so cute that should be your requirement
well more escorts will have that with us
i will for sure you're our pimp
you're our pimp so wait we're the ones
have to [ __ ] now and you're not
how does this work she's gonna be she
just costs more yeah i'm just uh no i
could be a taste test yeah they're like
do you want the owner or do you one of
the trainees i could be a
so like i'm i'm going to see this is how
good of a pimp i am i am going to go in
there first i'm going to examine their
penises for bumps for weird lesions for
smells
and then i will do just a couple blows
right just like yeah
and then see if he's uh you know a fine
young gentleman and pass them over to
you no you blindfold him and then you
leave the room and then we go in yes
i was just watching a final destination
that happened it was final destination
five have you not watched those movies
they're the best movies they're the
first no but that's probably exactly
what i'm looking for so thank you okay
so you know what the premise is yes
that's yeah they they they're they're
they escape someone has a vision of them
all dying and then they escape in time
and then you know destiny comes to get
them each time so in this one there was
a guy getting he went to go get a rub
and tug at a asian massage parlor and
the woman was so mad at how rude he was
being the hot chick at the desk that she
was like okay so she brings him and then
she just brings this old lady in and the
old lady's like giving him all these um
you know pins for acupuncture and stuff
and then something happens like a fire
starts something and he rolls over and
he falls on all of them but that doesn't
kill him because final destination
there's always like 20 things happening
that could kill him and so he rolls over
then the fire starts and then it comes
towards him and he's like ah and he's
like escapes it the fire goes out he's
like oh thank god and then a big buddha
comes and smacks and crushes his head
spoiler alert
at the desk there's so many beautiful
deaths so many gorgeous ones todd and i
are going to write a final destination
17.
[Laughter]
well i guess it's come time that we will
see our slugs next year after this
and we love you so much this has been so
cool yeah wait i want to ask you guys
something to go into the new year if you
think this is true
do you feel like the more you learn
about life about yourself about
the your higher self do you think that
you i always feel like i when i was a
baby i was born and i knew like
everything
and then i forgot it and i'm relearning
stuff do you feel that way i feel a
similar thing which is
that not when i was a baby but when i
was a little kid i had this i think this
is common though like
i had this like spirit and energy that
has slowly faded and i'm like trying to
always reignite it yeah
maybe it's always there
maybe you got to stop staring at the
ceiling [ __ ]
go outside pop a gummy what pop a gummy
watch a final destination do you have
that kala like spiritually not what the
[ __ ] she was talking about yeah esther
you threw me off there for a second wait
what were you saying yeah it made sense
no like you know when you like learn
more about yourself yeah and you're like
you you hear these things and you're
like damn like oh and it feels like you
already knew it as a baby like i feel
like we're born into the universe with
like the the knowledge okay
and then once we like we make some sort
of like deal where it's like if we're
gonna communicate we have to like
forget everything and so then once you
start talking stuff you don't remember
it but i just feel like when i'm
learning all these things and i'm like
growing as a person and finding myself
out that it feels like i'm like
oh i remember you knew this yeah it's a
you're concerned so connected to it yeah
okay
i guess in a sense yeah there is like a
purity in childhood and maybe there is
this like
you know you almost want to like
recapture that like blissful state that
you're in when you're a child that
wonder that excitement that lack of
judgment that fearlessness that you're
just like i'm gonna do that that
sponge-like nature to be like i'm gonna
absorb the world and everything around
me but as you get older and a lot of
these things happen to you yes yes
yes what that's how you think she's
explaining the thing i said i apologize
as well i agree i i i
um
but you lose that bad things happen you
start to overthink this big adult brain
starts to get in your own body just like
conditioning right right so once you
shed that and you you really work at
trying to shed those things that aren't
real and you get back to the core of
yourself you will find that fearlessness
and that like
vitality and that want to you know to
live a big life and
yeah so
but it's hard to get through that thick
layer that you build yeah that you know
you got to kind of shed a second skin
and you have a choice in it too because
i always feel like old people either
like bloom out or bloom go in you know
so i think for 2022 we should all bloom
bloom
hell yeah we're late bloomers that's all
it is we're just a little late to bloom
well who's younger than us doing better
than us we're doing good
i think we're blooming right on time
here we're doing good
we're on time bloomers yeah and we hope
that you guys bloom with us shed that
[ __ ] [ __ ] we'll see you guys bye guys
cheers bye
[Music]
you